it's my mission to show how much more
consensus there is than controversy this
would be perfectly honest Michael Pollan
really nailed it eat food not too much
mostly plants right you could find a
study that has almost any position you
want out of the context of all the
literature that they're in what gets the
click bait going here it's everything
you knew for 50 years is wrong right who
wants to click on something that says
you should eat more vegetables really so
I've been approaching it uh in my
studies trying to make it practical more
vegetables more Whole Foods less added
sugar and less refined grain The Click
bait doesn't work but we really all
agree on those